[Music]
with mark why do you say that you
weren't surprised when the child
pornography charges came about he always
was a very dark soul to me Naya Rivera
speaks out on her ex-boyfriend and
fellow Glee star Mark Salling in June
the actor pleaded not guilty during his
arraignment on two charges of child
pornography I just always felt like
there was something that he was
wrestling with the 29 year old opens up
about their former romance in her new
tell-all sorry not sorry
explaining why she's now grateful their
relationship ended in 2010 after three
years of dating
she writes quote when Mark dumped me I
thought it was the worst thing ever but
can you imagine if that didn't happen
and I was laying there in bed when the
battering ram came through the door and
when it comes to dating advice
Rivera recommends quotes have that one
relationship where you look back and ask
yourself what the hell was I thinking
you'll learn something and you won't
regret it unless of course that
relationship was with someone who had a
sizable stash of child porn on his
computer then by all means regret
everything
[Music]
you
[Music]